spiking gas prices energy prices biden
is now set to give one major address
about the economy wrong january 6th here
with reaction former white house chief
of staff reince priebus along with the
author of the upcoming book come on man
the truth about joe biden's terrible
horrible no good very bad uh presidency
fox news contributor
that would be joe koncha of course they
want to talk reince about january 6.
that's all they've got
i don't think it's fair in light of
secret service agents questioning their
star witness on facts to hear from them
i don't think it's unfair to bring in
handwriting experts i don't think it's
unfair to see if anybody was told to let
people into the rally on january 6
and not go through a metal detector
those are things we could find out in a
day or two isn't it
a hundred percent sean
the deck was stacked early on as we all
know when the republicans were kicked
off the committee by nancy pelosi but
look the democrats are looking for any
unicorn they can find to save them from
the dead whether it be january 6 whether
it be abortion whether it be guns i mean
this is the secret life of joe biden
he's living as you pointed out he is
living in in the world of his own
fantasies and you spelled it out we
talked about gas prices he's oh it's
putin's fault i mean forget about all
the executive orders that he signed that
you've talked about a million times the
abortion opinion oh they're going to
come after gay marriage next and then on
inflation today he says oh well the rest
of the world's got it a lot worse well
you know a quick little search on google
will tell you that our neighbors in
canada and mexico their inflation number
is actually lower than the united states
so look they've got to change the
narrative they're grabbing at anything
they can find because people aren't
happy and when you're not happy you
can't win elections
if democrats in the number of 78 percent
joe concha if they think he's doing a
horrible job uh
can we interpret that the polls the
predictions of so many of a wave
election are real or is it too early i'm
one of the superstitious type of people
i'm you know what until those votes are
counted and tallied and until we have
more integrity in our system i always
worry uh until i hear we can now project
well it's a yogi bearer right it gets
late early around here and it's 129 days
away to your point sean a lot a lot of
things can change but inflation's not
going away anytime soon and the gas
prices are going to be lowered anytime
soon and the border is not going to be
secured as we know so those three things
stay in place and fentanyl is coming
into this country in record numbers
killing a record number of americans
particularly young ones then americans
are going to vote with their wallets and
they're conscious and in this case and
this by the way this drives me crazy it
bears repeating mr biden says we have a
lower inflation rate than other
countries in the world let's list all
the countries that have a lower
inflation rate than we do i know you
touched on it before but but you know
i'm sorry i'm sick of this president
repeating this lie over and over again
so here's the reality china saudi arabia
japan switzerland indonesia australia
south korea singapore france south
africa italy india germany mexico canada
all have a lower inflation rate than the
u.s 16 and all and
china's inflation rate is four times
lower than ours so you know
the president keeps saying that no we're
right on par with everybody else or
we're we have a lower inflation rate
it's simply not true and if you tune to
you know abc nbc cbs cnn they don't list
those things and say this president is
lying to you and that that's what drives
me crazy as far as americans being
dissatisfied with the direction of the
country well you have an inflation rate
that's at its highest rate since the
early 80s gas prices all-time high a
border like we just talked about and a
president who seems too old too slow too
incompetent to solve any of these
problems and that's how you get here and
a good chunk of responsibility lies with
our media by the way who were so hell
bent to get rid of donald trump they
didn't bother looking at the guy who
replaced him and joe biden who has been
below average in everything he has done
his entire life and has failed upwards
all the way to the presidency and that's
what the new book thank you for
introducing it i appreciate it the come
on man is all about out in september you
could pre-order it now man you forgot
the rest of the time come on man are you
are you a junkie are you a junkie that
was one of my favorites yeah
um the democrats are going to run reince
you run a lot of elections january 6th
abortion the second amendment and the
playbook of republicans are racist
sexist blah blah blah is that going to
work
it's not going to work sean because if
you think about where these races are at
these these
there are not many races in america that
are in play and where are they in play
they're in middle road districts where
70
of the democrats i said that right 70 of
the democrats are also saying in those
polls that the country's on the wrong
track and it's about the economy stupid
and and and the secret life of joe biden
is not going to convince a bunch of
people that have less money in their
bank more money in their gas tank
tuition isn't getting any lower that
somehow or another life is pretty good
it's not going well for joe biden and
people know it
all right reince priebus thank you for
being with us joe contra congrats on the
new book we look forward to reading it
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else